um so first i kind of want to just jump
in because john obviously you've got to
be this character for suicide squad and
we got to see just a little bit of who
peacemaker was but can you kind of tease
for people who don't know the character
or people who are getting excited about
the show what they can expect to see
yeah this is this is a guy who certainly
thinks he is the status of a superhero
and is hit with some with some pretty
bold truths that he
he is uh a little bit less virtuous than
than he sees that man in the mirror and
in going on another quest
he's brave enough to face some of those
bold truths and find out that he is
heavily flawed and i think uh the
intrigue to the character came from
his ability to do such uh for lack of
better term shitty things in the name of
peace
and his
core value peace at any cost is a
contradiction in terms that's quite
interesting and uh you'll you'll get to
explore that a little more as we go
through the series
when did you find out and how excited
were you when you found out you were
going to get to bring this character
from suicide squad into the hbo max
series
i i don't want to use a bad term but i i
i pooped my pants i was so excited i was
like oh my god i get to play this
character um you know uh
so i you know at first i was just like i
was playing it really cool because you
never know what's gonna happen um at
some point he told me um that amelia was
going to be
a part of the series and i thought oh
cool you know i'll i'll get to uh hang
out and play a little bit
i found out really late into it like
james called me
and he said just so you know
we're doing
a peacemaker spin-off show
he'd already written like first drafts
and i was like what when did this happen
and
he's like i didn't want to tell you
and get your hopes up in case it didn't
happen
and um
so that was like late september early
october and we were shooting in january
so it was
a complete shock it was a thrill to get
a call from james gone who i really
didn't know that well um and he said i
wrote this part for you and uh you're
you know you're this dad you're a
horrible heart human being and uh i'd
really like you to do it i said sure i'm
in man let's go so
uh archie bunker on steroids kind of was
the way we kind of cyphered through what
this guy was peter for you on this one
what are you most excited for the fans
to see from the series
uh you know i'm well obviously i'm most
excited for them to see john cena
dancing in his tighty whities
that is something that i think everybody
everybody needs a little bit of that in
their life in fact a lot of that in
their life but but i think i think
really just the opportunity to expand
what james did in the suicide squad and
you know you're limited in a two-hour
movie in terms of how much you can
develop these individual characters
particularly with a large ensemble so to
have eight hours to be able to really
explore all of these characters not just
john but also you know leota and
harcourt and economos and everybody else
and to have james's unique point of view
on all of them it's just it's just a
pleasure i mean people have never had
that kind of opportunity to to enjoy
james's content for such a long period
like this i feel like we definitely got
to see in the end credits sometimes some
of the improv and like playful parts
that don't end up in the full episode um
how often were you guys breaking on set
or did things where it was like um maybe
that was too far
yeah
that happened a lot like a lot it was i
mean there was one scene with you it was
a there was one line
oh i don't know uh it's in the trailer i
think yeah how do you do with the with
this when you when you do badly in
school am i allowed to say that oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah what do you do when you
only get fifty percent in school yeah
yeah
yeah every time i was on the other end
of that scene so i wasn't on camera and
chuck and and and john would do that
line and you know you do takes like you
know 10 20 times because you have to do
it from all the different angles and
every single time they did that
i burst into a stair i had to hold my
nose
and it didn't get old every time i
watched it over and over again every
time they did it i i just lost it i
actually laughed when i saw it on the
trailer again even though
we did it
to answer your question there was a lot
of laughing and it wasn't just the
actors the crew the camera man james
gone on the god mic snickering i'm sure
matt was figuring something that you
know produces corner so that was such a
joyous thing to hear because i feel
personally
when you get the crew the hard who are
hardened professionals to be that
involved in the emotional life of a
scene you know you're doing something
good you know
i want to just hear how you would
describe the dynamic and the energy of
this show
i i think this show is is really like
nothing else that dc has made so far
it's
it feels like very much of a singular
voice and in the same way i wouldn't
it's not really what you asked but in
the same way it's not but like in the
same way that when christopher nolan
sort of took over the batman franchise
it was of a singular voice it really
felt like very specific tonally this is
obviously like an infinitely different
tone and it's much more playful and
irreverent and comedic um
but it is very singularly
from one guy's head
and
so you know that's the best way i can
describe it is is
in the a dc show a superhero show about
a really deeply flawed human being
through the mind of james gunn